just five days now until the first group
of ccsd students are welcome back to
campus
and a major update from the district
this afternoon giving details on
opening plans for all grade levels good
afternoon thanks so much for joining us
at four i'm kirsten joyce
and i'm christian casares today district
leaders saying they plan to bring back
all students before the end of the
school year
for some type of in-person instruction 8
news now reporter kirsten drummond is
live outside peterson elementary school
with all the latest details kristin
kiersten and christian dr jesus jarv
revealing the reopening plans today at
this campus
for grade levels beyond pre-kindergarten
to third grade students
we want to lay out those dates so take a
look here this is the
timeline we know that some lower
elementary school students are returning
march 1st to a hybrid model
but the proposed timeline has all ccsd
employees back in buildings
no later than march 15. on march 22nd
grades 6 9 and 12 will likely return to
in-person learning under the hybrid
model that date is also april 6th for
grades 7
8 10 and 11. also on april 6 the
district wants pre-k through grade five
starting five days a week in person
learning so that means
fourth and fifth graders are coming back
likely on april 6th
and will not participate in hybrid
learning and that's where students
attend class
in person two days and remotely the
other three days in the week
doctor jarrah says the state easing
school opening restrictions last week
helped speed up the process
he adds the district chose 6th 9th and
12th grades first
for a reason you look at our sixth
graders that have not been in a school
in their middle schools all year and our
high school
uh ninth graders as well it was an
opportunity for us to get our kids in
for a week
to transition into our middle schools
and high school before our upperclassmen
showed up
it remains unknown if secondary schools
will transition to full-time
in-person learning five days a week
before the end of the school year
doctor jarrah says it depends on how
well safety and health strategies
are preventing the spread of kobit 19.
the agreement to reopen
all the grade levels still needs to be
reviewed by the unions
and of course the board of trustees
still need to approve it
reporting live in lost in las vegas
kristen drummond 8 news now